안녕하세요 어 빌사남이 간다 오늘은
성수동에
왔습니다 오늘 저랑 좀 걸으면서 지금
이쪽부터 연무 장기를 좀 둘러 볼
예정이에요 저랑 한번 같이 따라서 갈
예정인데 저 가기 전에 저기 뒤에
저희가 중계하고 설계하고 공사했던
건물 있거든요 땅이 되게 작았어요 한
2 30평 대인데 건물을 저렇게 높게
올렸습니다 그래서 한번 현장 가서
살짝 보고 연무 장길로 이동해 보도록
하겠습니다 가시죠 적 돌로 마감을 한
건물인데 디자인에 되게 신경을 많이
썼습니다 지금 여기가 아무래도 중공업
지역이다 보니까 이렇게 건물을 좀
되게 알차게 어 지은 건물이라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다 지금 여기도
보면은 아치형으로 이렇게 좀 이쪽에도
디자인 포인트를 좀 많이 뒀고 여기
창도 이렇게 통창으로 줬고 여기 약간
라운드 되게 어 이렇게 만들었는데
되게 섬세하게 신경을 많이 쓴
건물입니다네 그럼 이제 본격적으로
연무 장길로 한번가 보시죠
[음악]
사실 성수동 이쪽이 대림 차고가
이쪽을 이제 좀 그 뭐 리모델링을
하면서 여기가 되게 유명해지기
시작했고 그래서 지금 여기 옆에도
무신사 스토어 들어와 있거든요 그래서
여기 지금 사람들 되게 많네요네 아
연무장 길에 왔습니다 역시 평일인데
사람이 되게 많네요 외국인들도 진짜
많은 거 같아요 그래서 좀 많이
보였던게 이제 일본분들이 좀 많이
계신 거 같고 여기 예전에 진짜 공장
밖에 없었는데 그리고 대부분 다 이제
오토바이랑 낡은 공장들 제 거래
자체가 좀 그랬는데 진짜 확
바뀌었습니다 최근에 이제 작년에
매각된 사례들이 있는데 지금 알레스카
건물 옆에가 이제 대지 평당 2억
5천에 팔렸고 그다음에 그 좀 더
가면 2억 6천 그다음에 더 가면
2억 7천에 최근 팔린 사례가 있고
암암리에 지금 실거래가 신고는 안
됐지만 한 3억에도 팔린 사례가 있다
뭐 이런 소문도 들고 있습니다 거래도
되게 많고 그리고 여기가 워낙이
중공업 지역이다 보니까 땅 활용도도
되게 높기 때문에 정말 여기 평단가
팔린 거 보면 웬만한 강 남 진짜
앞구정
로데오나이트 넘는 어 그런 평단가를
찍는 거 같습니다 그 무엇보다 제일
부러운 거는 여기 알래스카 사장님
신사동에 있었거든요 근데 신사동에
원래 임차로 있다가요 건물을
16년도에 매입을 했습니다 그때 당시
한 49억 50억 정도에 매입을
했는데 땅이 100평이 넘어요 근데
위치가 되게 좋아서 어 최소 300억
이상 되지 않을까네 그렇게 생각을
합니다 사실이 가게로 그렇게 많은
돈을 벌기 쉽지 않잖아요 근데 그때
당시에 워낙이 사장님이 매입을 굉장히
잘하신 거 같습니다네 그래서 디올
건물 앞에 와 있는데 여기 좀 디올의
역사가 좀 있어요 디올 건물 소유주
분이 원래 그 택시 회사 법인이
가지고 있습니다 그래서 88년도에
매입을 해서 아직까지 가지고 계세요네
정말 저는 그분이 존경스러운 거는
수많은 뉴욕에 거하지 않고 매각을 안
하신 거예요네 매각을 안 하시고 원래
택시 회사 차고지로 사용하고 있다가
어 계속 이제 가지고 있는 와중에
성수동이 개발되면서 이렇게 올까지
들어오게 된 겁니다 돼지가 무려
712명이에요 평당 2억 정도라고만
쳐도 진짜 한 1400억 15500원
가까이 됩니다 택시에서 안 해도 돼요
아마 임대료도 꽤 많이 나오실 것
같아요 그래서 지금요 건물이랑 저
앞에 건물도 있거든요 그래서 같이
하면서 어 임대 수익도 좀 상당할
것으로 예상이 됩니다네 저도 mg
세대에 맞게 한번 사진 한번 찍어
볼까요네 그리고 저 mg 세대
[음악]
맞습니다네 저는 지금 아뜰리에 길에
구키 씨라는 카페에 와 있습니다
그래서 오늘 좀 연무장 길을 좀
돌아봤는데 연무장길 진짜 사람이 진짜
엄청 많은 거 같아요네 진짜 정말 좀
손꼽힐 만한 그런 정도 유동인구가
있는 거 같고 진짜요 최근에 본 거
중에 명동 다음으로 제일 사람이 많은
거 같습니다 그래서 그 정도로 어
유동이가 굉장히 좀 많은 거 같고
여기 아뜰리에 길은 연무장 길보다는
사람이 그렇게 많지 않아요 근데
아뜰리에 길만 한 그런 좀 느낌이
있는 거 같습니다 어 그리고 무장길
같은 경우에는 그 용도 지역이 중공업
지역이고 이쪽은 이제 이종 일반 주거
지역이에요 그래서 건물이 아무래도 좀
높지 않고 그리고 여기 이제 건물
리모델링 할 때는 대부분 다 적벽돌로
되어 있어요 그래서 그 기준에 맞게
그런 방침이 있기 때문에 건물들이 좀
다 비슷하고 뭔가 아뜰리에 길만의
그런 특색이 있는 어 그런 곳인 거
같습니다 그래서 날씨가 좀 더
좋아지면 여기 서울숲에 오셨던 분들이
여기 오기 되게 편하거든요 어 그거
유동 인구에 맞춰서 아뜰리 길에
사람이 좀 더 많아질 것 같습니다
그리고 뭐 연무 장길도 똑같고요
그래서 연무장길 메인 같은 경우에
아까 뭐 2억 5천 2억 6천 2억
7천에 팔린 사례 말씀드렸고 그다
아뜰리에길 같은 경우에는 한 1억
중반 정도에 매각이 돼요 그래서
가격이 굉장히 많이 올랐습니다
아무래도 여기가 용도 지역이 그렇게
높지 않다 보니까 어 제 개인적인
생각에는 좀 가격이 좀 꽉차 있지
않나네 그렇게 좀 조심스럽게 예상을
하는데 이종 일반 주어 지역 치고는
가격이 좀 많이 비싼 거 같아요네
그래서 1억 5 천이면 거의 강남구로
치면은 세로 스킬 쪽 아니면 이제
압구정 로데오 같은 경우에 한 2억이
다 넘기 때문에 그거보다 좀 못
미치긴 하지만 성수동 내에서는 가격이
좀 많이 비싼 거 같습니다 그리고 북
성수 같은 경우에는 1억 초반대
수준인 거 같아요 대부분 길 보면
가격으로 치자면 북성 수가 그래도 좀
저평가돼 있고 가격이 그래도 뭐
1억대 1억 초반 정도가 많이 있고
그다음 이제 아뜰리에길 같은 경우에는
한 1억 한 초반에서 중반 정도
때까지 매각이 됐었고 그다음에 여기
이제 연무장길 이쪽은 지금 거의 다
다 이제 2억대 2억 5천 그 이상
찍을 정도로 가격이 많이 올랐다고
보시면 될 거
[음악]
같습니다네 그래서 오늘 영상은
여기까지 하고요 여러분들이 혹시
가보고 싶은 아니면 저희가 한번
분석해 봤으면 좋을 만한 그런 상권을
댓글로 남겨 주시면 다음 편에
참고해서 찍도록 하겠습니다 여기서
마무리하겠습니다 빌딩은 역시
빌사 h